[Music]
what food podcasts Happy Holidays to
everybody here we go G go Tory with a ho
ho yeah man yeah man oh Lisa Esparza
over here chillin taking knows doing
taxes doing everything over there silent
partner Aaron back over here with a
wheel dos deal what up everybody we're
doing it man
lot of things to get over with man I I
can't watch starting I live because I
work Saturday nights but I got to see
the Foo Fighters kill it well there's
Christmas sweaters singing ever long I
waited here for you then I switched to a
Christmas song and those women killed it
on that song and then it switched to
Charlie Brown then they yeah the code
over Merry Christmas and then a tweet
went out after that
why people finally because the America
is oh my god for reals wrong about happy
I'll just say it yes what I'm saying did
you start with some hoot so many
Merry Christmas
please leave me nothing a bunch of it up
big how do you say happy holidays
instead just to piss him off he'll
understand and then Natasha a monster
catcher Happy Hanukkah they uh they got
a holiday card from their neighbors and
they tweeted it it said I'm happy
holiday crossed out in April Merry
Christmas
whoa it said not it said it said Merry
Christmas and it said not holiday and
then Moshe said our neighbors understand
us so well merry holidays
merry holidays happy holidays no I'm
also saying happy christmas happy
christmas and a ho ho ho to you I love
Christmas
I love the ho Christmas season I wish
she'll be like this all year but he was
not freaking out huh
was the Elf on the Shelf he was Chapel
we're back people we killed everybody
solos all shows that uh yeah yeah we did
yeah I'm about Thursday but Sunday was
pretty good but it was like Jordan eight
people on the first night huh well
you're supposed to get extra merch from
FedEx the FedEx up and weren't
they didn't deliver it till Monday guys
are gone then they changed it and said
oh it's actually coming Tuesday I called
it and they said okay well we'll send it
back to Memphis I was like Memphis
it never was in Memphis oh that's our
hub it has to go through Memphis and
then we'll call you and then what and
then you tell us what to do with it I
said why can't you just skip the Memphis
part and just send it back here back
home to LA oh my god I'll take his
photos outside on on Thursday right yeah
and some guy could go to me in the line
amen
can I buy that sweater off you know let
bang yeah you're killing me it was the
last one weeks old yeah but see what bit
where's his comedy magic one watch full
sleep with it yeah mellow stressed out I
did the hard work but it's a lot of fun
so my side of it already
I'm giving $40 cash put in my pocket
went home got another one so yeah man
so our merch never got there but we had
a good time over there are we wait oh
man
the places we ate no I ate a whole foods
everyday so cute stupid-ass security go
follow me around what about that because
I saw your story about that you didn't
tell me this story though well we got
there now your Instagram was no security
guy walking around you nobody know I can
follow at the whole food here by the
Mexican cop but but our yeah
I never noticed him so later always said
that we're eating our whole food source
re-recording him for the first cop or
the second cop cop or a security guard
he was all decked out like a cop but he
was a security guard what I wanted to
make sure because that Whole Foods has a
bar in there serving alcohol and I
always know that in Texas they have
alcohol there's a real but that gather
was part of his security guard the black
officer was up with a no-no they were
both from the same thing but the guy
looked more official cause he was off
that looked at the dad and family matter
as a black cop yeah the other one was a
bald one my plane depart stiff back
prevent anything dude it's gonna do get
push fast they stole the power bar get
him yeah man hey even though the sample
dude there was no samples over there
daughter just had crumbs
I hate when they have crumbs dude that's
weak dude if I was a manager at that
place all those samples will be like
dude enough for like 20 people to grab
real ones over when I first thought I
think about a boss that boss he was done
bro that's all he wanted remember
samples at Costco the best the best
sample story though is when Felipe was
taking Isaac around at the mall in the
food court they're sampling everything
they get to this Chinese place that has
wings they have hot wings right and they
give out samples of different flavored
wings so they're out a whole wing I
think our little drumstick yet so
flavorful but yeah they're all different
flavors why see garlic yes so Isaac so
the Isaac and Felipe went up to the wing
plays the Chinese place in central rows
they were out so they said well we need
to make some more and so I said let's go
shop and then we'll come back all right
so we came back after like an hour and a
half of shopping yeah so we go back
after a long time and he goes up to the
lady the sample lady and says who sorry
we took so long getting back
I laugh so hard because he just was
thinking that they were expecting him to
come back because he said he was coming
back he's like oh sorry took us so long
to get back did they have him yeah he
came back to let me have it it did it to
a little you're killing me you know that
he told us to know you're killing me man
what are you do it here how long it take
that's what I'm saying
I know we're no sample lady and example
a $35 to set your pad at her and make
these quesadillas that's a worse dude or
how about a sample guy it's a sample
guys all why do like 49 think - to get
sanity make you something you know we
never made that before
yes we don't reach what you doing you
make this you can make it like if I eat
us and then I really put heaters vaginas
yeah man I think bad if it's Christmas
there should be a nice every store
should be sampling everybody a
whole cake bro like like you could put
on a whole cake on there for the people
what am i a choice test our
father took it as a father didn't even
have cake for us dip that fingernail
frosting dude yeah man Trader Joe's has
good samples oh yeah but a lot of people
don't have samples I like those those
are those Latino markets like Liborio
yeah they don't but you know who does by
yata in that other one North Gabe you go
there's like a party they give it out
chips and like salsa and no tacos
like you know grand opening maybe at the
the Grand Central Market at the Grand
Central Market on Broadway downtown is
the place brothers they saw stop work or
bro straight a pig like carnitas right
there bro and you go there can get a
sample
they're full of they just give you a
sample bro he grabs the tortilla I mean
I've been steaming right there I let her
cook tortilla jiggle it's a little steam
one it's marinade water stains and a
little thing of this team or they know
they never been open since they got in
there yeah a little in a plastic bag
Melton yeah so he takes one out it's low
steamy and then it was his plastic
yeah he's wearing gloves by the way
plastic gloves he grabs a tortilla bro
brother scoop of the corn it
ain't just got and he hands it to you
brought a little a little wax paper bro
so I'm saying I didn't care if he wasn't
wearing let me tell you why I there's
some level right there size that you
want to really try a Papa dude that I
took what I take to I took Chris Torre
no there bro Wow Brown's good
bro bro I wish I ate this when I was a
kid bro you guys got a good bro were so
oh that crackling noise
diverticulitis bro bro yours what's your
favorite out Christmas story bro
Christmas movie Christmas story please I
mean I like a lot of Oh bro my top file
out to be Christmas Story one cuz I
could watch that over and over and
I watch you over and over here dude I
just like Christmas vacation with Chevy
Chase
yeah it's good little white-trash
Christmas it's good right of course
Santa Claus the first one three that's
just funny one little bully killed a
booger fool I realized okay Jack Frost I
realize the movie was shot in Long Beach
really it was I'm sorry
weird maybe show you know what their
rent right there with the night with her
scene where they're hanging out and it
was it was shot right there and where we
at the backstage of um
tropic Elia right there at UM what's it
called the Queen Mary yeah really that
little area I went the first home alone
I was upon them and Santa Claus okay it
was supposed to be set in Florida or
Arizona right but it was all shot in
Long Beach and that mom was dead album
ah ah well you have seen the Jackie
Brown yeah and that girl walking around
when he's looking at her checking out
her ass that damo mom and I mean I
started noticing a Brooklyn I'm thinking
a bar I've been a Florida I know that
I'm not looking at something out over
there
always cloudy it's a filtered Sun yeah
man welcome to Florida Jacksonville
ma'am do we know the loony Bin's yeah
man so that's my third and also like
what am I like
man like home alone bro I love them the
first one the best yes you know it's not
really I will probably be number five
number six kids not really a Christmas
story but there's a lot of Christmas
teams in it trading place it with Eddie
Murphy and then accurate yeah dude well
how would that food off that's a real
bad Santa bro well he's down and out bro
and F we walked into that birthday with
that Christmas party it just
walks out with a piece of salmon
and then even a bus all dirty and a
salmon full of here that's a
badass movie no do yeah man so
that's my third right and also men
there's a lot of my bro but the ones I
can't really think about oh of course
lethal weapon one bro that's the
Christmas movie run it starts off with a
buy Christmas trees and it ends
on Christmas Day when him and Gary Busey
are fighting they're playing like
rocking along the Chris oh and I'm
thinking about another one that's good
bro but um I guess I gotta say that I
like we're talking about the five best
Christmas movies and I said that I of
course Christmas Story one Christmas
vacation to past past answer three
number four it's not even a Christmas
story but I'm home alone you're crazy
Scrooged has to be in the top five oh
you should get forced to watch that like
it's cool you're talking about a
Christmas carol zoilo Bill Murray foods
with Bill Murray that's the best one I
prefer Caddyshack II also but it's not
even a Christmas story but the elf
either
I like elves a badass movie house I seen
that shouldn't the theater do I have to
say that's my number two dog
in the world now I let go that but then
I there are some September 29 or 729
pretty nice training yeah yeah happens
in like restaurants and you love that
you love that one restaurant with movie
with Stanley Tucci right the Italian
restaurant I do man I like that one
and you also love the part in Goodfellas
where they're making a dinner like you
love watching the process of making
dinner and good for that tree but when
they're slicing the garlic took that bro
because he mixes it with the with the
sauce why it's too hard too strong
really American it up a little bit I
mean I'll catch up on your stuff yeah
Kelly I don't know those East Coasters
bro but even in the prison when the
prison scene there the good yeah how do
you how do you like your steak
medium-rare I'm an aristocrat okay so
that was that bro so it's cool shirt
Jimmy was so fool little crack me my
boss so I didn't like that so two
brothers at the class with Tim Allen
what fake bad guy and I like
that uh that uh Twilight Zone Santa
Claus with Art Carney that fool down in
now Santa Claus he's like a bum and he
finds his bag and he look what's your
favorite toy walkie-talkie
there's even in there he just took it
around oh my god
it just takes up residence bro portal to
the nother dimension yeah man like that
okay here we go Brown everybody and when
you go in for
so Chris story we live with Christmas
bro the happiest place on earth bro
where Disney am proud you go there every
every year no are they really coming
down it's part of the drama yeah he was
in on it the whole time he's part of the
drama the suspense
we might have a few people over for some
tamales vegan tamales vegan plus all day
I don't think we're inviting Fred's
dollar this Monica that he was
complaining at that what that Arab girl
the Christmas parties I met dr. drew
well he wanted suit oh my and I so I
have Pacific Cantor's or what I thought
help us all day he's like is that too
spicy
don't put anything in it you'll be fine
what's up fool December 27 benefit for
Flacco at the ice house I'm hosting a
show my team on Rizzo Marcin Rizzo Gina
Torres Brian McDaniel loose Palacios
loose battles okay
loose parcels well this show is called
to be colder I took Farkle to the
hospital one night yeah and also January
5th I'll be in Boulder Colorado
the boulder theater generally says
Portland Oregon Revolution Hall January
12 Chicago the big theater January 13
New York City January 13 New York City
tell all your friends
PlayStation theatres january 20
Coachella spotlight 29 January 27 to
saneras onna at desert diamond saw what
he thought so I eat that
January 16th I'll be at the brain prop
Rodrigo Torres and homies
Jojo and homies oh yeah Brown put on the
show bro special gas bro so bond oh
you pop hey bro what a breath fat well
at least over just a black during the
dark side
oh you guys see Star Wars your hair now
bro I don't know nothing I don't want to
see it so couches we're gonna still have
some couches see ya right bro oh my god
is fall asleep in there doc yeah what's
up fool they were guests today bro hell
yeah dude hell yeah we've to be with a
state major maverick oh wow back in the
days right oh yeah and the last
survivors bro she left before everybody
and it was late luenell we would I
thought dirty does is bro she started an
accident we were the ones that change
that he couldn't dump so he was late you
never tell you he loved you companies
I'm keeping you guys but he didn't tell
you mr. Feldman just took up with him
mr. Belding it's about Dean Saved by the
Bell say where the bellerose big are you
serious yeah
he went to Abrams took him you only took
him but then he called like a month
later and said oh I don't know if you
know but I moved I meant to tell you I
thought I thought I told you I said no
you didn't tell us I don't think it was
ever actually with them I think he just
kind of said I was I know you another
guy man who who just used to have the
ICM had Roger Paul Waner ICM hat in a
coat all about Montreal past about the
other part I got booked on a sitcom in
2015 and and JC actor had nothing to do
with it
and I ended up having to pay commission
for that series regular role yeah how is
that possible
I just I should what I should have done
looking back fought it yeah I fought him
well I fought him cuz he wanted your
touring money from yeah I should it was
18 no wet his beak he wanted like he got
a cut of the winnings from Last Comic
Standing because he puts you on that but
he thought he was getting a cut of the
touring money from Last Comic Standing
you fought him oh yeah I said but you're
not booking that tour you don't have any
cut of his stand-up here theatrical
that's it and he was like oh he knew I
should have hi you know what I was - he
knew I know so we have Rebecca Corey
people I'm good how are you how's the
dogs well Sally came in all tough
talking looks like a little line
there's a Corgi there's a all here right
now we're gonna and that's Todd they're
good they're good they're both rescued
and alive so that's a good thing
what's up fool how you been right you're
like one of my favorite people on the
planet have you been yeah we just got
back from Addison we're gonna rush okay
special you got a special yeah I know
congratulations yeah we did ourselves we
didn't have to share the money with
anybody you just shot it yourself yeah
yeah we heard that we heard the crew
and they did the editing and everything
but they were on a skeleton budget and
we paid for it all ourselves
you just presented it and then we sold
it to HBO but they don't buy many
special things done before you know they
loved it oh good good good I'm glad I'm
happy for you you're one of the good
ones you had a rental car commercial
wait what a random thing to bring up
what happened that was a huge campaign
you got to give up your agent at
maverick because I was never with
maverick but I do want that money back
I know right 18 grand he got from me
I'd like to simply a bit of margin
drizzle oh they just that would they
just accepted the check the straight
Jack like most agencies do on his behalf
and then they never gave him what's
going on what is going on we live in an
end times
some people like again when you start
off like yeah just be my manager for
like 20 years how you know agent already
showed up that manager at six you know I
mean and then he goes well you know I
might she says she gets all my checks
you know she's signed up why why does
she stay unchanged yeah Bob right is the
business great no she just does
everything you know they literally cry
cause they don't have nothing
well four agencies most of them can
accept checks on your behalf you read it
out on because they get the payment they
take their Commission out and they give
you the rest but a manager shouldn't you
have to sign up form to allow that I
know and you didn't have that form he
didn't even know my social security
number or my maiden name I'd been
married people don't know that and so
you called me as a cab your social
security number heavier man I said no
what are you talking about well you know
I made the call to get no you didn't I
got called indirectly
that call made a call he didn't even
know when I had callbacks he didn't know
when I do you love that I'm just like
saying it let it out I'm letting it out
I've led a lot of out what happened you
be a Rob before right I got robbed but
it wasn't like from an agent oh really
I thought up immortal aids here man no
money for real like robbed not robbed I
got like Jax like I had money like cash
money you know went in there took it and
then I'm next to have that deal what the
she dad flipping everything over
nice and I just took off I was like
we weren't a GoPro when he does that
hell nah sitting there and sweating in
like June and landlords can be
shady dude you knew somebody else who
was getting robbed by their landlord -
she was coming in and digging in their
drawers and stuff right yes sir on
camera they had her on camera finally
and got her busted yeah and then they
won one time I when he pawned when you
recording her she won't care about God
yeah because I think she came in ready
to fight somebody
cuz you can fight what did you shoot him
walk in the hood he wants to be a word I
hope somebody in here because they're
not supposed to go in unless there's
like a gas leak
then that room is probably not register
at the rental place
who knows just kill somebody before so
what's up man
well would you get started in comedy
when did I get started we're shocked ah
go for G cago no I grew up in Seattle
but I moved to Chicago when I was 19 and
then I went through the second city
training program and then studied at the
annoyance cedar and then I ended up the
last two years I was in Chicago
I like improv but I don't like improv
games and so like if I'm on the
stage with people doing games I'm like I
always say out loud break the reality
and I'm like oh stupid yeah I don't like
games so I dumped out of that and then
and I think people were happy I mean I
didn't do it anymore and then I did
audience warmup at the Jenny Jones Show
for two and a half years yeah and that's
how I started getting into stand-up
because I'd be out there Jenny Jones is
just the most unpleasant and she would
have like hair issues on the regular so
I'd be out there for three hours vamping
and after a while you just like five
days a week it was a five day week show
and it was so much work and it's you
didn't have an act when you started that
you just know you just huge audience I
meant to be out there sometimes I was
out there for like an hour and a half
after leading like not ya and trying to
come up then I figured after a while I
started figuring out things I could do
and then pretty soon I realized it
wasn't really an act / sex I didn't
really know but it was like things I
could go to that I knew that the crowd
it was a very urban crowd and people
were fun Johnny Jones show was so
popular and Springer taped across the
hall and it was crazy and so that's when
I started doing that I did that for two
and a half years and then moved out here
and then like in 2001 I did stand-up for
the very first time at The Improv and it
was a showcase for the Montreal Comedy
Festival for new faces and I got in and
with that five minutes and it was like
you know it was an amazing year I think
I think like Kevin Hart me DeRay Davis
Dean Edwards that was I think I think I
may have been the only woman maybe one
other one but so 2001 really and then
I'm just been plugging away yeah
acting and crap you know
you know doing that yeah still doing it
with now now on tour nationally with my
foundation that's what I want you to do
a show
what's your heart lesion the stand up
for Pitts Foundation started for Pitts
bro Sandefur Pitts got two of them right
here
Todd's from rescue from a dogfighting
operation with the black one
yep and Sally is just severe neglect and
abuse over breeding yeah yes a lot of
over breeding in dab Quigley I can't
even look at her well there's this girl
on Instagram they follow she's selling
her puppies from I can't
it's brutal yes I knew a guy well I want
to see him yeah man this guy in the
projects bro all right we're doing a
housing projects playing with the
weekend cap you can cap no Erica animal
let it after that a hamster cockatoo not
even a fish do you what they have but
people have fish this guy we lived in a
four-bedroom apartment with his whole
family a bunch of girls and my friend
nacho now for breeding Dover you're
breeding now
Rottweilers bro like Rottweiler Pro like
then we on site eating brought our
edible housing projects there finally
somebody stopped on its own you're crazy
dude
well you bring all these dogs he's
probably selling them for a hundred
bucks you're selling them but every time
I bring it up with my I see my friend
sometimes in the street was - am ia
death to find him dogs let me do air did
you hustle bro tacos
yeah very similar very similar but yeah
my like I don't like or sometimes you're
like at Walmart
usually like around 2:00 in the morning
you come out and there's like this meth
head out there with a box
I know yeah ma'am you want to just buy a
little puppy and I food a little puppy
dogs gear like he is the baby has been
don't have a shot you know what to say
yeah yeah I wanted to buy the dogs but
that I don't want to see I don't want to
keep it going you know it's like let's
just hopefully get this dog that was so
scared take that dog I wanted to pay him
20 bucks for that was a little chihuahua
thing and it was so scared and cold and
it then it threw up some something
it was probably heater or something but
it just threw up it looked like its
whole intestines right in front of right
in front of us but Danny was so scared
and he snapped at everybody who came by
he said he hates everybody
like I wonder why this dogs been abused
they do in the world Mad Max well that
but then I was like that dogs gonna it
won't come to me for one - it's gonna be
even more scared when it gets in our car
three I don't know what kind of things
it has when you exterminate man like you
go to people's houses you're like how
could a breed all these cats
when I was putting in air conditioning I
shall kicking them out of their houses
and grabbing up on the floor I will go
into a house the old man you know an old
man was like 13 cats there's cat food
everywhere and there's baby cats
everywhere - like you live like this
that you can't even run I know oh it's
brutal man the house stinks all that
they shouldn't have humans either a
lot of that's why I keep my humans away
when do you start your foundation I
started it in 2013 just at the end like
September of 2013 because I organized a
march on Washington DC to help raise
awareness about dog fighting and breed
specific legislation and we made us
history it was pretty pretty epic like
we marched on Washington and 5,000
people came from all over
the country in world been rough it was
actually called the 1 million pibil
March so we marched and did a I got the
I organized it myself got the US Capitol
the West Lawn and we rallied there and
it was pretty great pretty cool pretty
cool to be able to raise awareness about
what's going on with these dogs cuz it's
pretty crazy the cousins - I mean the
only thing I've ever been to live or
cockfights
you know that's a big problem here - you
know they have a man Odessa Texas bro in
Midland Texas um I always say that when
I was working over there the comedy club
Larry clothes everybody was to present
but um wait everybody went to prison
from the comedy club yeah they were
involved in nefarious activities
dogfighting it was just a hobby for them
the owner the owner goes up a man goes
to a fight later on after you take a nap
from Radio and I said I would like my
way covers what's a fight at 3:00 in the
afternoon on a Friday Hill now I'm good
man what kind of was they later on how
were the fights and it well yeah it was
good man I'm my dog my dog kicked ass
thing I didn't lose okay I didn't lose
2500 I do that that's how much every dog
is worth but I'm yeah by the word so
regular dog fight you know goddamn dog
fight that's actually a federal offense
I thought of a regular fight but now man
with a bunch of local guys local
neighborhood we had deal it's a regular
thing in that neighborhood
they all went it's disgusting yeah I
grew up in East Asia East Dayton was a
hub for like Oh like in indoor gambling
like illegal video game gambling and
then also dogfighting it was huge and
they would steal stray dogs yeah and
train them and they were bait basically
bait dogs and that was happening all
throughout our neighborhood and we my
mom rescued all those little dogs and
we'd go feed all the strays and
every night i want i wonder how these
these little markets and maybe the way
was so much gambling like when I was
living in that's where Larry Flynt and
his brother grew up well now living in
diamond Street right there know what I'm
living at Diamond Street wasn't about
the gang neighborhood but now living in
downtown on Boylston the asian guy here
arcade and one of the machines with a
regular slot machine there people losing
money all day and we need money to
sitting there for hours for hours it's
all just a machine maybe they're paying
somebody what's up fool
what's happening so how long you been a
doctor for a long time um yeah I mean I
started yeah what made you start this
well I dog named angel came into my life
she was rescued from South LA and
someone had dumped battery acid on her
back cut her ears off with razor blades
or scissors and she was in the pound and
no one was gonna get her at the last
minute of small rescue got her and I
started fostering her and then just
hurting became really educated about pit
bull-type dogs and the stereotype and
the discrimination they endure and that
85% of all dogs and shelters are pit
bull-type dogs and they're not pit bull
is not a breed it's it's a breed but
these dogs are all called pit bulls
because of how they look it's a term
based on how they look and so I was just
like wait so we're killing millions of
these dogs and calling them dangerous
and violent because they have short hair
and like beefy shoulders like that's
insane and then just started realizing
the underground world of it all the
dogfighting of it all the discrimination
people can't get houses or insurance
their apartments they can't you know
just because they have a dog that looks
it's discrimination it like the most
insane level and so just really pissed
me off and so I started I just really
educated myself about breed specific
legislation and how shitty the law was
and how awful it was and just believed
like look at the discrimination that
people deal with every day it's like it
just all bleeds down it's the same thing
so I started fighting it
still em and prep and always will
because you know they're they're born
inherently good they're innocent
voiceless beings and it's human beings
that are up and dangerous not
dogs so yeah my foundation is saved a
lot a real thousands and thousands and
we have a ripple effect because we raise
like this year I think we raised 77,000
for nonprofits nationwide and no 77,000
and then 67,000 and funds for nonprofits
nationwide and my foundation raises
funds to last year we spay and neuter
for low-income families 430 animals
which was amazing around the country and
like you know we do we do a lot of
really a lot of ripple effect work like
at the core that will help save lives
for years to come not just taking dogs
from the pound and saving them we're not
we don't have rest we're not a rescue we
don't have Fosters but we support a lot
of people who do and save a lot of dogs
that way that's great
and we run a dogfighting tipline in LA
County so I have a private investigator
that checks out the tips and we have a
relationship with law enforcement and
county officials and what should people
do if they know about dogfighting in
there very good question if uses what's
that house I put some money down that's
the problem with murica no I
that's a good question well first of all
I want to say you should care because
where there's dogfighting there's always
other crime so these guys that are dog
fighting dogs it's like what you said
earlier it's just a tip of the iceberg
there's usually abuse of children
assault battery people sleep there too
are you serious yeah I would come on if
you have if you like playing with dogs
yeah I wouldn't doubt it I wouldn't
that's the kind of mentality because
it's just that they're they're not
humans or animals anymore they're
objects their money-making objects and
yeah if you see money making out of a
dog they're gonna sing but some people's
are also just breeder for show right
yeah well that's that's one thing we
fight because it's like why are you
breeding more dogs
yeah there's millions dying and being
thrown in garbage bags every year who
are amazing these guys are from the
shelter there's amazing dogs in the
shelter and they're full they suffer
good coin though right
it's so annoying yeah it's like and then
those dogs they you know they're a gift
they get in the wrong hands they end up
in the shelter we end up having to mess
more people get pitbull in the beginning
like for their babies or for them to
realize they can really no wasting them
back they just drop them off this drum
away at the pound it's really sad but I
want to answer your question about what
should you do first it is don't look
away you got a care and if even if you
don't like dogs I say this to people all
the time it's like if you you don't like
pit bulls or you don't even like animals
at all it doesn't matter
a dog fighter affects you if you think a
dog fighter isn't capable of burning
your down or stealing your car or
robbing your whatever you're wrong so
you should care and then evidence is
always great you got to be careful
though but you know any sort of video
footage photos witnesses is great you
can only in LA County they can call the
tip line which is one eight seven seven
seven seven seven to five 85 anywhere
else in the in the country can call the
HSUS
tip line and if a fight is in progress
call 9-1-1 it's a federal offense
they'll go to federal though if
prosecuted they will go to jail
I'm remember like we know the kid
growing up I don't even know that the
little rascal thought with a paper to
later on right PD I realize how can they
cut my mom how come they got the ears or
make him scary because Peter was cute
right I'm he the pit bull right yeah
from the rascals like yeah like Todd but
Mackenzie's a type of pit bull terrier
there you go yeah American Pit Bull
Terrier is the technical that's whether
look what yeah but if you were to like
swab the inside of Todd's face and swab
the inside of Sally's mouth they would
just be months because but they're
called pit bulls because of what they
look like yeah it's crazy but there's
really only one American Pit Bull
Terrier and they're always pretty small
however watching the American the
American pity talking about in a cartoon
he was always a drill sergeant and why
don't they get that terrible rap like
you know that they always well kid
supposedly movies to probably redo that
movie tomato me dogs the Doberman
Pinscher gang you know that movie that
were the Dobermans rob banks know they
should be a guy a marina 80s called a
Doberman Pinscher gang the guy walking
was seven Dobermans with a pouch and
they were and they were like there was a
grounders guards and who robbed the
whole bank
yeah they had like a message they're
gonna redo it you know and then you know
you know what happened they were trying
to do a cute movie go by and by dogs
okay read more dogs
the following year yeah the following
year the shelters will be full
government pinchers but what happened to
our Easter rabbits and ours wrong on the
rabbit that we got it was a gift a
Valentine's Day gift to this girl and
she don't want it of course and it's sad
and I said color it but at the time we
didn't know what she was but yeah she
shadow
in a case no human once a day in the
yard like a prison name oh my god oh
love here brought her home she was the
first time she got out huh she sat with
us for our when you start your when you
start your foster program for rabbits
even though we stand up for Pitts will
we'll help you out yes stand up for
bunnies it's pretty legendary he's got a
huge following on Instagram I think like
35 31 grams where we take a picture of
you guys
mr. Todd and Sergeant Sally mr. Todd
search and Sally on instagram galaxy
okay you can pick him up if you want you
don't care let me get this Sally back up
man she's a big-headed beast
[Laughter]
how cute
[Music]
[Laughter]
here let me take a picture yeah you'll
telev a picture sit down guy there you
go take a picture are you such a skinny
I guess we're getting a pimple did I
take it already yeah I took a few too
cute I want to be snacks so are these
your dogs now that you've adopted them
and and have they busted a lot of dog
fighting operations here in LA County
operations across the country every
multiple times a day every day did that
Michael Vick stuff give it any credence
well you know it's it was good because
it showed people that it's happening
that it's happening and he ran a huge
one for a long time it's I think it's
empty
he's only 40 exterminator I'm gonna make
we're gonna made a donation to your
thing are you serious yeah I just said I
was gonna make a donation too you know
oh my god are you kidding me thank you
so much
that is amazing I saw your ugly
oh I can't believe that I'm gonna I'm
blasting that out to all of our
supporters thank you so much a lot of
dogs came in during the fires too huh no
I mean we don't know about the I don't
know about I know he is we have a rabbit
[Laughter]
[Music]
the podcast he's in the microphone look
at him yes I have some things how do you
know that this isn't this isn't a
playground dollars to the stand up or
Pitt's bounty thank you so so much I did
not expect that at all that's amazing
you're gonna have to do the show at some
point yeah what a big Doug we did it at
the Avalon theater this year oh yeah
yeah it was incredible
but yeah sold out it sold out in seven
days 555 people in seven days with no
lineup that's crazy oh no it's amazing
so you have to come I think I asked you
to do it right yeah were you on the road
or been busy like every weekend this
year yeah you were just like the body of
my leg are you are you kind of afraid of
dogs no no it's just he's never had any
pets his first pet real pet was our
hamster two years ago then we had a
rabbit that got sick last but she got
better last last year she was very sick
are you guys vegans too yeah oh yeah me
too
well do some traffic
we'll do a beginning for desserts what
if I would have known a little next to a
specialty vegan cheese shop in Hollywood
that's across the street from the Laugh
Factory and their cheeses are literally
unbelievable they're expensive but
they're all vegan guy and they are so
good like okay some cheese and bread
today that cheese platter they have a
crossroads it's delicious oh really
oh yeah they have like a roasted ricotta
and it's like roasted on the outside
it's like flame uh-huh and then they put
a little apricot glaze over it and you
spread it on your bread yes
have you been across on Melrose I have
not oh oh yes I've been there was
everybody somebody and then I got a good
look at it like I got a really look at
him that I'm staring what we call a love
connection happening here todd has went
ahead and said could you be my forever
he wants to play now you're not playing
[Laughter]
pause I know I know I guess I got a good
dog soon huh well let me know when
you're ready yeah oh yeah what kind like
five will take older ones yeah
he's playing you're not how old is todd
todd more like two and a half yeah he's
he's a young guy he does love you though
that's for sure but I've seen pit bulls
and bunnies get along I've seen some
people with lots of different
oh god wooden Todd loved to play with a
bunny yeah I just gotta get to know
today was so they're the first in the
rabbit went out today because I was cold
and play dating yeah man hope that helps
it's going to absolutely help I cannot
believe how sweet that is that is
so sweet thank you so much oh my god
sighs that what you been up to you uni
TV work no I just finished the tour
stand up for Pitts
well the one in Hollywood it was hosted
by Kaley Cuoco and Bob Saget steve-o
Josh wolf fortune teamster myself and
Adam Ray we're all performed and I'm
actually um yeah but fortune doesn't
have any pits she's got like two small
dogs but uh Kaley Cuoco has three she's
post the event every year she's done it
for seven years and so that was great
but I also did two coma Portland I do
helium Tacoma communicated your life to
this whole thing yeah like you changed
your whole career and all that stuff a
hundred percent a hundred percent yeah I
mean I mean ultimately there was a point
when I was I was on a sitcom in 2015
and I was doing both and I was like I
wonder what will happen like if I'm on
if I'm on a series how will I be able to
do both
I did I did it was insane but so yeah
and I you know I'm writing and I have a
script at a production company that I'm
taking out in January and hopefully will
sell I used to be a janitor on airplanes
it's called cabin service I mean my
friend's mom does that on American Oh
leans out the cabins after everybody me
too that's what I did for like two and
half years so I loved it you gotta be
faster well there's through flights and
then there's overnighters don't get it
twisted
so overnighters are when you got a
deep-clean that plane everybody's gone
they're gonna take off that's right
you're scrub in the bathrooms and
toilets you'd be emptying the garbage
restock and the liquor kits you're
cleaning the windows a tray table I knew
was under a seat
what'd you say
[Laughter]
a used condom my club will be a vomit
lots of vomit weird places that people
like would be embarrass maybe and then
hide it but like you like you're not I'm
not gonna find it like you're gonna rat
you're gonna barf in a McDonald's bag
you're gonna wrap it in a blanket and
then you're gonna hide it like you think
know what like it's gonna magically
disappear so yeah I mean it was a so
that I wrote a pilot about cabin service
about that time yeah it's really funny
and it's so we'll see so you know just
grinding as usual and you've been in the
news lately - yeah I believe I have I
believe I have yeah I mean you were like
the first person well no you were
mentioned with two others in the louis
c.k stuff it was actually five of us
five total five total yeah but yeah we
went on record mhm
yeah and you were doing a pilot at the
time with David Arquette and Courtney
Cox Yeah right I was producing right in
writing and starring in it yeah
and that's when it happened and what was
louise role on he was acting a guest
star mr. yeah as a guest it was actually
right before he did Louie his show so he
was like he was a big deal yeah and he
was but yeah he was just a Q as a guest
star you know on the pilot and yeah I
mean it's a it's a terrible it's a you
know it's a he never did anything in
front of you he asked you to if he could
do that
I did not yes he asked if he could
masturbate in front of me and in my
dressing room as I was walking to set to
shoot my scene he just kidding me no
because he wasn't kidding no cuz she
said she reminded him that he has a wife
pregnant wife and a kid yeah um yeah and
I was like no and I was
like crazy like what and you had no
interaction with him before this though
throw me off like what are we're
throwing you off yeah it's a bit - a
loop like it's and I and you're walking
on the set to shoot a scene like it's a
really there's a lot wrong with it
there's a lot wrong with it so yeah and
I it was it was time to because you know
the one thing that like you know I'm
actually gonna be publishing an op-ed
about my experience because you know the
New York Times doesn't say what the the
they say the facts but they there's a
lot more that goes into and what you
know there's consequences that are far
deeper and far-reaching more than what
just happened you know because you also
people ask well why didn't you talk
about it away and you tell somebody and
you actually reported it to Courtney and
David I didn't through the proper
channels they gave me the option to have
him removed and shut down production or
to keep going and I didn't I didn't want
to be responsible if you can imagine
like I'm saying the word responsible
when I didn't do anything it's the part
of it that's the catch-22 of it all I
just didn't want to be the person who
who did that because you just don't want
you just you it's a terrible position to
be in it's a terrible it's a terrible
decision to have to make you know it's a
day that you should be excited about
that you've worked so hard you know we
pitched the show all over town and Fox
bought it we're excited about being
there you finally get to tape day you're
in hair and makeup you're in your you're
walking to set and then you're sitting
in a dressing room having a conversation
and being forced to make a decision that
you should no one should have to make
that decision and so it sucks it sucked
then it sucked all the years following
it for many reasons which I will talk
about and it has been terrible since
speaking out it's been terrible oh yeah
it's been a crush for you oh yeah from
other comics well a lot of the comedians
have been absolutely silent about it
which is upsetting because if if it's
gonna be a safe environment and truly
equal for everybody and we can protect
one another then you have to address
that it happened you know you have to
admit that it happen but like it's yeah
it's been pretty quiet
it's been real real quiet and it's been
really upsetting to watch people I you
know respect and call friends like just
outright defend the behavior cuz you
know hey he didn't rape us so how it's
not that big of a do you know it's like
that kind of talk and it's like wow you
know it's been it's been it's not it's
not been cool people look nerd thing
about oh man
that was that would never stay like oh
that was Joy's sister though remember
before that was about happens but I was
Jewish did you up into his sister you
know there's no talk like that like that
could be somebody said there's no
personalizing but making that person a
person it's just this right it's very
strange and I know that girl like she's
a good friend of mine never like that
exactly well then like although the
late-night talk show hosts every night
they are ripping on every single male
predator that's being taken down daily
right not one has mentioned Louie CK
that's their colleague yeah everybody's
kind of like holding their weight back
right now to see kind of what happens a
lot of dudes are afraid to speak out on
it you know I think it is but what are
they afraid of you answer me this what
exactly could not Conan O'Brien be
afraid to say and here's the thing to
here's gonna back up another redhead
rule it's only two
he worked there the whole unit mean all
that thing friend party started but you
know but here's the thing let me address
that because I get it and I've thought a
lot about this I've had 12 years to
think about it okay so and it's
terrifying to speak out like the month
leading up before this thing came out I
can't even just put into words what it
felt like I
it still is awful because it's not what
should it's not what defines me you know
I have a lot of accomplishments and I've
been in this business a long time and
done a lot of great things and to be
known as his victim is is humiliating
accuser yeah it's like they don't call
us victims because he admitted it all
right we're victims yeah but if they
don't admit it
it's alleged accusers so here's the
thing I want to address it you were
saying it's like you know I got I have a
lot of friends in comedy who I love and
a lot of men I love him so much and if I
if it came out like Mike one of my guy
friends in comedy was pulling his baby
dick out and acting like just being a
repugnant filthy animal that's for you
say that because I I for two more
Reynolds on one time that there were a
backstage and he was take out with a
chick and then another committee took
out his penis and it was a baby dick and
my chin goes the other girl got grossed
out it was why you leave leave him there
I want to do that catch it gross you
know I can't leave my friend out of that
little thing my team of verify who that
guy was if you were here buddy I was
yeah I just whipped in our blade without
even like no hello no nothing okay she
was a banshee with a fan of the show
just whipped it out and it was my thing
goes bro you just changed everything
right there because you know we were
probably wouldn't get laid but now it
looks like
work grows sandwiches I felt I felt part
of that I like I was a pervert now
because I knew the guy but that bro
I go I left them all for good I left I
took God
I told that girl you know what I don't
know I don't really hang I wasn't going
as much I never had a baby dig but
that's gross right I'm not the one I've
never been the one to to do that but
like just whip it out you know be kind
of appropriate cuz I have everything I
just know I can't because my mind
exactly that's the thing like that part
of the Act
yeah that's okay show your gut all day
Jodie's to as many telling show his
testicles on stage it was only on stage
he never whipped it out yeah there's a
big difference the cape and
everything if you like if you approached
me and asked me if you could masturbate
in front of me or you just start doing
that as a thing you're my husband that's
gross
I don't want to watch you masturbate I
don't want you to do that to me you
wouldn't even ask to do that to be
either calling me wrong it's in the
workplace it's it's it's preparation
it's a girl it's B it's past now you
were saying that at that time he was a
big deal yeah well you read his
statement didn't you no oh I didn't get
too much sit down and have a read on it
he talks about how he revealed it his
power and it's not about it's it's about
power and breaking people down it's it's
a it's really dark but I want to
address what you're saying about the
guys not being scared and all the late
night talk show hosts not addressing it
no one talking everyone acting so
shocked and stunned here's the deal I
put myself in their position because I'm
a decent human being and can do that and
it sucks like if it if it came out about
when I loved a very close friend of mine
I'd be super upset about it I'm not
gonna lie and I wouldn't know what to
say and I like Sarah Silverman in her
statement I felt I would probably feel
the same way like I don't really want to
address this because it's uncomfortable
I loved that person I never had that
experience with that person but it's
terrifying to find out that this is what
that person can do and is capable of I
get it I get that it's uncomfortable I
get that people don't want to talk about
it they don't necessarily know what to
say but I also think too bad
that's how I felt for 12 years so you
better talk about it you better address
it and you better acknowledge it because
if you don't you're condoning it and
that pisses me off so it's like you
don't know what to say you're
uncomfortable alright well take a few
days think on it
sit down and think on it talk to your
family about it talk to that person
about it
but to not to go out every night on a
late-night talk show and deliver
monologues and rip on every single
person Oh Riley and how francon did all
of them fear so much as I think it is
either I think they're one they like the
person of course which is and it's hard
to reconcile that this person was just a
line
yeah that's understandable and what
you're said about Sarah someone's
statement is true I think that she put
it into good words like I love this
person I thought he was great and I
never happened to me but I am shocked
him disappointed I'm sad what he did was
wrong yeah in Bama admin kind of said
the same thing she's his well he was his
wife on lucky Louie little show voice of
Bobby Hill she has her own show that he
produced but she she um she said the
same thing she was like I'm shocked and
I'm disappointed and I have to figure
out what I how I feel about all this you
know and she didn't say any more than
that yeah she probably should yeah yeah
she probably should say like you know I
dunno how I feel about it you can't do
that to people you can't do it
just women either it's like there's a
lot of men who've dealt with some real
gross creeper situations too like was
Kevin Spacey - like it's pretty gross
cruise agent yes so I said I I do I do
know though that there's this weird
Allegiance in the comedy world about not
not not addressing it more so than
anywhere else I hope that change and I
think because it was him because Louis
was held on such a pedestal by so many
comics and revered is like okay the new
you know Carlin level sort of person
they're waiting for their special come
out each year and you know and then they
have to kind of eat crow everybody kind
of has to eat crow and go this guy isn't
as great as we thought
wait you mean is masturbation bizarre
hilarious I mean his whole act I saw
what semester big and I was not crazy
right yeah yeah but I do
III did I did look I admire the work he
did and there's nothing wrong with that
right but I I think he's absolutely
disgusting and I couldn't I couldn't
yeah it's good times you guys it's the
holidays well now I know why he had
different black t-shirt I'm why well we
talked about it were you thinking I'm
not gonna talk about this we're not
gonna talk about this we're gonna talk
to her about this you'll read a book
about it I wanted to bring it up hell no
you did I mean I'm happy I'm gonna
publish an op-ed piece about my
experience and what it's all what the
whole thing is when it happened
welcome to priority who maybe just shut
up never stay like this no because I
didn't I didn't he didn't do it in front
of people it was just to me and then I
went and told the head of production
then she went and told Courtney David
and then that's where it left it
up to me what to do and then I just made
the decision that's the shitty part even
though there's a lot of really I
know but you know as a woman you get
that in that situation a lot well what
do you want to do about this do you want
to do this or this and they're both
really shitty choices yeah and it's like
well I don't want all these people's
jobs resting on my knee imaginers I know
and then you've got that thank you very
much and then that's right you know so
you're you're into vin trouble in your
own mind you're you you very shortly you
know and you didn't do anything wrong
but as a woman you get a lot of those
situation you were at the wrong place
with the wrong time and he came face to
face with a monster and it doesn't
always have it doesn't always happen
with sex or whatever but it's just
you're often given that responsibility
to make that choice and I don't think
guys are given those choices like that
you know what I mean it's it's kind of a
woman thing it's like this almost like a
mom thing you know like okay I'm the mom
so I have to choose between this or this
I don't get a choice that I really want
you know it's interesting no that's what
you're saying is as this conversation is
good conversation is good it needs to
happen I mean people who have children
you know and daughters and sons and like
they need to be talking about this and
being like hey guess what it's not okay
to know a friend of yours is doing that
and lie about it or condone it it's not
okay to do it to a girl you cannot you
can't shove a girl you can't pull your
dick out you can't masturbate to
fruition in front of a girl you can't
assault you can't harass you can't all
those things are not okay and that's
just like it's it's for the first time
ever it's really weird how and great how
at the same time and uncomfortable and
repulsive but needed this whole thing
has become the conversation has become
daily and I think that eventually it
won't but maybe there'll be change I
hope there is for sure
where is sagging all this by the way
because I was wondering weird is like
you know like sag AFTRA you know what I
mean like they
they haven't said one statement because
their partner once they are technically
like if you get her on the job had a job
at Dodger Stadium I was part of the
Union yeah and if I had a problem with
my shop steward it and you take it out
with the owner of the place but there's
nobody in there and at these that when
you're working in a movement there's no
Union guy there there's nobody there on
protect you
yeah and there should be there should be
and but if you if you get hurt on the
job on a set they're more worried about
I use it in those hours yeah
well I get your emails from sag AFTRA
right all the time they're just always
about Oh workshop on this workshop on
that whatever where's the email that in
light of the recent events we want you
to be aware of our policy and what your
harassment saggin after no one is crazy
this is what your recourse to you not at
all not at all because do you know what
to do no I I did job with a union if
this would have happened the hope people
get shut down there's not even a union a
corporation you know get on your ass
right away yeah that would not be yeah
but right here in a movie still you
gotta go to the what its first AED you
don't even know you do although speaking
of those Hertz commercials when I did do
those they had a big meeting before that
it was a sexual harassment meeting that
discussed what would you write
but nothing there's nothing that's like
hey when you're on a sitcom or we're on
a set shooting a pilot and a predator
approaches you and and says in a real
creepy way yeah anybody in a state yeah
what what are you supposed to do are you
supposed to stop in that moment ring a
bell raise your hand like a jobs sizer
there's signs you know for harassment
there's time for discrimination hosters
they're size for the break room and all
that being dirty
interesting
there's all sorts of rights and you know
you have the right to go report it but
um yeah that's really that's a really el
canal they've been the most silent I
think of all this I have not even
thought about that
hmm that's we were talking about that
the other day like where is that we
should be awarded free health care for
the following year yeah man
for therapy if we want I've gotten death
threats fans are from professionals or
do you know yeah not professional the
professionals are just more silent just
staring silently yeah so they can have
him back on their show but no it's just
it's his compulsive masturbating fans
who were like you know going at me on
social media the Jerky Boys masturbation
is overrated man yeah it's weird yeah
right
Gilbert Gottfried on something he was
showing his family hidden documentary on
Gilbert Gottfried and his family oddly
enough the family he's kept quiet for
years but he was talking about really CK
and he said I prefer to keep that just
between me and myself I don't like to
involve other people in that behavior I
don't think that I really in my opinion
I'm no psychologist you know and I'm
also no prude either like I'm not known
for being like really clean or PC but
it's a female comic you can't be too PC
about that stuff because it's around you
the discussions it's everybody sad
boners are funny Bulls are funny but
here's the thing I don't think what he
did or what he does or what any of these
guys do I truly don't believe again I'm
not a doctor not even close I have a 7th
grade math level but I will tell you
this I think that I feel like he these
men have this is more about power this
is a sickness this is
this is something much much darker than
just like hey I got a boner here it's
not that it's I really don't know it's
more about there's something like
predatory there's it's it's deviance
it's like I know I'm doing a guest star
role in this show you're producing but
I'm more powerful here cookie was a
goner bathrobe that's right that's right
there's something dark about it yeah
give me the movie but arm if you see he
wasn't going to kimono and fondos anyway
he have right I am miss tag after Union
huh bag after a union I should talk I
should call my sag after unions we're
official poverty is if you're sick when
were your ass done honest really cuz
they haven't said anything I haven't
seen one thing come across from their
mouths about just in case we want you to
know are they are they busy HR and
recruiting and staffing and cific and
something happens like this in the
environment is such where all this is
coming out left and right
in the industry we would put out a
statement look in light of recent events
we want you to know you have a confidant
here you have you know a group of people
you can go to you can go to you don't
feel comfortable with this manager
you're going to these managers you're
not alone there's nothing from sag and
you know it's a different you have to
admit there's a different environment in
entertainment in general but when
they're sag AFTRA as a representative
you know they're responsible as well I
believe I think you're 100% correct and
maybe I'll make a good call and put
maybe I'll record it and put on sir we
call that chilled man - I know be
somewhere honest look I voted for you
and you're a woman and you're open about
pregnant yeah but you know this stuff
begins listen
I mean seriously though it's happening
the artists woman's it's all these
actors I'm Willie Barcena
he should go pick up script from his
manager that Larry has managed it's a
guy with scripts heat oil as his office
was in the living room first that's the
first warning right there little sign
when that you know he would answer the
door his underwear and no socks with
kids what do you think about it like
what if you knew a comedian that did did
you know Louie no he's known some
skeeves you know some some creeper guys
oh yeah would you would you what would
you do if that was your what would you
do if that was your guy friend what
would you do
who beat his ass you would be this
would you do if somebody asked
me what I would think about it I would
probably tell you can't go you can't go
you know go get a little prostitute or
something can't go to Backpage or some
I bet it all out I was comedian man
they've been so loaded that they're not
you don't know I know
the only comedians I'm door the only
well I work with a bunch of comedians
there was one female and I remember that
one comedian not gonna her door at night
hey what are you doing in this party
like what are you doing you
pervert yeah but she started joke around
and she was telling you nothing it was
funny like Rudy up you know just you
know with all loaded out in my let's go
with all loaded knocking on my teens
still man what's up fool so what are you
next show for you - pitbull comedy show
I'm doing
that's a rapper by the way Nick's comedy
show involved in I don't have his number
got it or way you know come on
like he knows of my column does oh yes
please he's so positive oh the next show
the next show that we just finished the
year-long tour this two weeks ago and
now we are doing we start the 2018 tour
in New York City at Gotham comedy club
the last week of April I believe it's
April 29th and then we're it's still
determined how many cities we're gonna
do we did 13 this year and we may do
more we made you last next year
depending on my schedule looks like I do
them all so but the next ones then and
if people want to learn about what we do
go to stand up for pizza us and yeah not
to be my table Rodrigo stand up for
armpits what is the whip is again stand
up for pits us stand up for pits dot us
people I need you to promise me you're
gonna do one of those shows my will okay
I will man okay thank you so much for
the donation you're welcome Rebecca Cory
people are they do you think anyone's oh
well it doesn't come out so Freddie Mac
home then Carly in Ireland yes mate all
together Chris I'm out there in Dallas
you know that other boy I forgot your
name cuz I wrote it down on the sticker
and then I give the sticker to somebody
you know also our new listeners who are
listening to a podcast was up started
number one and then go backwards yeah
spay and neuter your dog like Bob Barker
I know I'm gonna bring that back closed
down pet shops why yeah
yeah I can't believe my friends have a
lot of dogs in the housing project I
think now in California pet stores can't
sell Pez that's right it's a new law it
just came out
all right just got I think it's
September 8 that's right thank you so
dogs you can have rescue organizations
or adoption agencies come in pet stores
not individual no but you're supposed to
have a license for that you're supposed
to be but there's again like when
there's millions of dogs in the shelter
what is the point of breeding yeah go
get a job get a job at a poky store do
pokey pokies a big thing here kill tunas
[Music]
did I ruin up the raft did I ruin the
wrap up no tell me everyone so fool I'm
coming to Boulder Colorado and then
portly stood lookout for those shows
yeah and December 27 Flacco's fundraiser
he might get a new heart and shout out
to my media Paul Simon you know who you
are
[Laughter]